[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend 9
Stunden im Flieger für gut eine Stunde
Gespräch das nennt man einen Blitzbesuch
kurzfristig anberaumt ohne autorage oder
pressebegleitung ist Bundeskanzler
Scholz nach Washington gereist dort gab
es dann auch keinen drumherum Tamtam man
saß im Büro des Präsidenten zusammen
Hauptthema der Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine das persönliche vier
augengespräch immer besser sind als
Videocalls ist nachvollziehbar trotzdem
wirft der Kurztrip Fragen auf gibt es
mit Blick auf die Ukraine
heikle-entwicklungen die man noch nicht
mal über besonders gesicherte
Telefonleitungen besprechen will oder
dient der Besuch dazu noch etwas
aufzuräumen im deutsch-amerikanischen
Verhältnis
Patricia Wiedemeier und Andreas
berichten
manchmal ist es besser man trifft sich
persönlich und beredet heikle Themen
unter vier Augen auch wenn man dazu über
den großen Teich fliegen muss für eine
stickvisite im Weißen Haus das ist der
Grund warum Bundeskanzler Scholz mit
kleiner Delegation aber wichtigen Themen
Joe Biden besucht
das ist ein ganz wichtiger Arbeitsbesuch
das ist ein Schulterschluss noch mal
zwischen der deutschen Bundesregierung
und der amerikanischen
regierungs-herze hinzubekommen was sie
gemeinsam erreichen wollen eine freie
souveräne wiederhergestellte Ukraine
müssen beide Seiten zusammenstehen und
eben auch für die großen globalen
Herausforderungen immer wieder betont
der Kanzler wie gut das transatlantische
Verhältnis sei mehrfach haben sich
Scholz und Weiden getroffen für die
Opposition jedoch ist es ein
überstürzter und schlecht vorbereiteter
Besuch beim wichtigsten Verbündeten was
ist eigentlich der Sinn und Zweck dieser
erneuten Reise sie ist weder vorbereitet
mit dem was sie uns hier heute gesagt
haben noch nehmen Sie Journalisten mit
noch haben sie dort einen Abschluss
Community vorbereitet
für Scholz ist der Sinn klar es braucht
dringend Abstimmung über weitere
Unterstützung für die Ukraine das
Gerangel um die Panzerlieferungen hatte
das deutsch-amerikanische Verhältnis
belastet auf Druck von Scholz hatte
beiden der Lieferung amerikanischer
Abrams Panzer zugestimmt nur damit
Deutschland seine Leopard Panzer liefert
und so hat der Präsident im Interesse
der Allianz und um sicherzustellen dass
die Ukraine das bekommt was sie möchte
auch wenn das nicht die Abrams sind
gesagt okay ich bin der Führer der
freien Welt wir geben Abrams wenn die
Deutschen den Leos hat liefern jetzt wie
gesagt wird es nicht mehr darum gehen zu
schauen wie kam es zu diesem Resultat
sondern die beiden Staats- und
Regierungschefs müssen sich darauf
konzentrieren wie geht es weiter in die
Probleme die drängen weiterhin das
wissen natürlich auch die beiden über
Verstimmungen will keiner mehr reden von
Putin lasse man sich nicht auseinander
dividieren Joe Biden lobt ausdrücklich
dass deutsche Engagement für die Ukraine
abgesehen von der militärischen Hilfe
die Deutschland geleistet hat ist ihre
moralische Unterstützung für die Ukraine
beachtlich Deutschland hat zudem die
Verteidigungsausgaben erhöht und sich
unabhängig gemacht von russischen Gas
ich weiß dass das nicht einfach war
zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist es sehr wichtig
die Botschaft auszusenden dass wir die
Ukraine so lange unterstützen solange es
nötig ist und ich schätze sehr die gute
Zusammenarbeit zwischen uns zwischen
Deutschland den USA und Europa
wenig Zeit für all die anstehenden
Themen geht es doch nicht nur um die
Ukraine sondern auch um das Verhältnis
zu China und Iran deshalb ist es wohl
doch ganz gut sich auf den Weg zu machen
zu einem persönlichen Gespräch
das vor einer Viertelstunde zu Ende
gegangen ist MRT gewesen in Washington
im Vorfeld wurde nicht viel dazu gesagt
Journalisten hat man auch nicht
mitgenommen haben wir gehört was hört
man denn jetzt in Washington welche
Themen im Vordergrund standen bei diesem
sehr vertraulichen Gespräch
ja wir wissen aus den beiden Umfeld dass
der Kanzler um diesen Termin gebeten
hatte da war man ein wenig verwundert
man hatte ihm auch ein Staatsbesuch im
April Angeboten der kanzlerwolle über
Strategie reden und wohin die Reise
eigentlich geht zu hören wir aus
US-Regierungskreisen und darum ging es
dann eben auch die Ukraine das
Hauptthema sicherlich da geht es um die
Frage inwieweit man eine Position
schaffen kann in der auch Wladimir Putin
bereit wäre eben Verhandlungen
einzugehen und das kann man aus
amerikanischer Sicht nur mit Gelände
gewinnen dafür gehören andere Waffen als
die Ukraine jetzt hat nicht
notwendigerweise Flugzeuge darüber wird
man geredet haben und das zweite Thema
ist natürlich China die Signale dass
China möglicherweise Waffen und Munition
nach Russland liefern will haben dazu
geführt dass die USA klare Ansage machen
wenn China das täte gäbe Sanktionen ein
Paket liegt hier parat und da wollte der
Präsident sicherlich auch den deutschen
Kanzler mal fragen ob Deutschland dann
mitziehen würde wenn es Sanktionen geben
gegen China geben müsste
dann haben ihm gehört es gab jetzt viel
freundliche Worte von beiden
übereinander aber zuletzt lief ja nicht
immer so rund Stichwort Panzer
Lieferungen ist denn die amerikanische
Sicht auf das deutsch-amerikanische
Verhältnis
ja beide Seiten reden ja immer vom
strategischen Gleichschritt indem sie
unterwegs sein wollen aber die
Amerikaner haben so ein bisschen das
Gefühl auf der US-Seite ist das
strategisch auf der deutschen Seite ich
sag mal eher taktisch das heißt man
reagiert auf die jeweilige Situation ein
Jahr nach der Zeiten wenn der Rede ist
hier in Washington der Eindruck
entstanden dass der große Plan fehlt wo
will man eigentlich selber hin als
Deutschland man hätte sonst die
Entscheidung über die Panzer über die
Leopard 2 aus souverän treffen können
ohne dass die Amerikaner Abrams liefern
oder Zusagen also es fehlt das große
Bild und die Amerikaner haben eine
nationale Sicherheitsstrategie und wir
haben danach gefragt ob das auch für
Deutschland möglichst schnell her sollte
und da wurde uns gesagt jedenfalls sein
die USA meistens damit sehr gut gefahren
ich glaube das ist das Signal weil
Deutschland muss sich auch Gedanken
machen welche Lehrerin es zieht aus
diesem Konflikt jetzt in Europa im
Umgang dann mit China danke schön für
die Einschätzung nach waschen
in der Ukraine wird weiter gekämpft und
weiter städtebombardiert saporizia
wurden in den Trümmern eines gestern
getroffenen Wohnblocks weitere Tote
gefunden wie furchtbar ist wenn man zu
Hause in seiner Wohnung ist und
plötzlich eine Rakete einschlägt hat ein
Bewohner in niebre unserem Reporter
hannah-hebestreit beschrieben in der
Millionenstadt war im Januar ein
russischer Marschflugkörper in eine
Wohnanlage eingeschlagen die Rakete vom
Typ x22 war ursprünglich dafür
entwickelt worden große Kriegsschiffe
mit einem Schlag zu versenden
entsprechend ist das Ausmaß der
Zerstörung dass sie in dem Wohnhaus
angerichtet hat
es ist eines von über
1309 Fenstern die Pavlo mit seinen
Kollegen eingebaut hat seit den nibro
Mitte Januar eine russische Rakete in
diesem Wohnblock eingeschlagen ist 45
Menschen starben andere konnten gerade
noch rechtzeitig aus den Trümmern
gerettet werden bis heute kämpfen viele
mit ihren schweren Verletzungen
gleich nachdem es Geschehenes ahnte ich
was auf mich zukommen würde ich muss das
jetzt alles schnell abarbeiten natürlich
macht mich das sehr betroffen aber wenn
ich arbeite schalte ich die Gedanken ab
kann das nicht er muss ständig daran
denken wie knapp er dem russischen
Raketen Terror entkommen ist er konnte
das Inferno Filmen während ein paar
Wende weiter Nachbarn ihr Leben verloren
ich war gerade dabei das Geschirr zu
spülen als das Haus plötzlich wie einen
Sprung zur Seite machte ich guckte zum
Fenster und da gab es schon einen großen
Knall das passierte in
Sekundenbruchteilen das Fenster ist in
die Küche geflogen ich rannte sofort ins
Nebenzimmer zu meiner Tochter die war
zum Glück okay
während der Renovierung wohnt die
Tochter jetzt bei Verwandten in ihrem
Zimmer steht der Kühlschrank in dessen
Tür das Küchenfenster gekracht war
Vitali zeigt wie knapp ihn dieses
Geschoss verfehlt hat körperlich ist er
davon gekommen kämpft aber mit schlimmen
Albträumen
direkt nach der Explosion ist ein Teil
des Wohnblocks eingestürzt da gab es
viele Schreie der Verletzten nach zehn
Minuten ist noch ein großes Teil
heruntergekracht und plötzlich waren da
nur noch ganz wenige Schreie zu hören
die Stadt bezahlt die Handwerker um die
Wohnungen zu reparieren bis zu 200
müssen aber abgerissen werden je nach
Ergebnis der statischen Untersuchungen
den vom Abriss Betroffenen helfen statt
und Region mit Geld für eine Neuanfang
oder wo die mir doch
gesagt jeder Wohnungsinhaber bekommt
umgerechnet 75.000 Euro um sich eine
neue Wohnung zu kaufen in der Stadt oder
außerhalb das machen wir damit die
überlebende nicht alle gemeinsam wohnen
bleiben und dann ständig über das
Erlebte reden das wäre dann ein Haus der
Trauer
sich bemüht die sichtbaren Spuren des
Krieges zu tilgen wollen viele Ukraine
nicht dauernd an den Krieg denken
[Musik]
Raketen fliegen verspüren wir Angst wenn
es ruhig ist vergessen wir allmählich
das Krieg ist
so lange bis eine neue russische Rakete
die nächste Tragödie anrichtet
[Musik]
die Nachrichten beginnen jetzt mit den
Streiks in Deutschlands zuerst zu den
Warnstreiks im öffentlichen Dienst im
Tarifkonflikt des öffentlichen Dienstes
die haben den öffentlichen Nahverkehr in
mehreren Bundesländern teilweise
lahmgelegt laut der Gewerkschaft Verdi
folgten rund 60.000 Beschäftigte dem
Aufruf und legten die Arbeit nieder die
Gewerkschaften fordern 10,5% mehr
Einkommen mindestens aber 500 Euro mehr
im Monat die nächste Verhandlungsrunde
in dem Tarifstreit ist für Ende des
Monats vorgesehen
und zugleich gab es heute auch den
globalen klimastreik von Fridays for
future mit zahlreichen Aktionen an
verschiedenen Orten in Deutschland große
Protestmärsche der Klimabewegung mit
jeweils tausenden Teilnehmern gab es
unter anderem in Berlin München Hamburg
Köln Frankfurt am Main und Dresden
gefordert wird unter anderem ein
Kohleausstieg bis 2030 100 Prozent
Erneuerbare Energieversorgung bis 2035
sowie das sofortige Ende von
Subventionen für fossile Energieträger
und einen ausbau-
der Güterverkehr in Deutschland wird
sich laut einer neuen Prognose des
Verkehrsministeriums deutlich ausweiten
bis 2051 um die Hälfte im Vergleich zu
2019 wir Minister Wissing sagte Reiche
der Ausbau von Schiene und Wasserstraßen
dabei alleine nicht aus es brauche auch
einen Ausbau der Straße
im Bistum Mainz hat es eine heute
veröffentlichten Untersuchung zur Folge
Jahrzehnte lang erhebliche Versäumnisse
im Umgang mit sexuelle Missbrauch
gegeben die Verfasser der unabhängigen
Studie kritisieren dabei auch die
früheren Bischöfe Volk und Lehmann zum
Ausmaß führt die Studie seit 1945 bis
2019 insgesamt 181 Beschuldigte und 41
Betroffene an der jetzige Bischof Peter
kohlgraf sprach von erschreckenden
Ergebnissen und Verbrechen ein ganzes
System habe versagt
in Belarus ist Friedensnobelpreisträger
altes
verurteilt worden er ist bereits seit
2021 im Gefängnis und wurde heute von
einem Gericht in Minsk laut staatlicher
Nachrichtenagentur unter anderem der
Finanzierung öffentlicher Unruhen
schuldig gesprochen er hatte mit seiner
Bürgerrechtsorganisation
Demonstrierenden geholfen die gegen
macht aber Luka schenkow auf die Straße
gingen
eigentlich sollte in Brüssel nächste
Woche das Aus für verbrennermotoren
beschlossen werden ab 2035 sollen nur
noch Neuwagen verkauft werden die keine
Treibhausgase ausstoßen der
entsprechende Gesetzentwurf war fertig
auf den Text hatten sich EU-Kommission
Mitgliedsländer und EU-Parlament im
Herbst geeinigt die Abstimmung darüber
sollte jetzt eigentlich nur noch eine
Formsache sein zumindest war das so
erwartet worden doch daraus wird erstmal
nichts denn Deutschland stellt sich
plötzlich quer genau genommen die FDP
was dahinter steckt und wie das in
Brüssel aufgenommen wird berichtet
Gunnar Krüger
wo wenn ich den Brüssel wo die Autobahn
ins Europa Viertel reicht wo der Stau
dazugehört wo sonst sollten Sie Ringen
um das was Autos antreibt los geht's mit
dem Green Deal der EU-Kommission darin
steckt das Verbrenner aus für 2035
nichts davon wird einfach es wird sogar
verdammt hart
er soll recht behalten doch zunächst
einigen sich die Mitgliedstaaten und
zwei grüne deutsche Minister tragen es
mit das Verbrenner aus schließlich
finden alle EU-Institutionen einen
Kompromiss den das Europaparlament
beschließt samt Prüfauftrag für eine
Zukunft des Verbrenners
ihm reicht das nicht der deutsche
Verkehrsminister stellt Bedingungen wir
sind bereit den Kompromiss der
Kommission zu unterstützen wenn
gleichzeitig die Frage beantwortet ist
wie Verbrennungsmotoren nach 2035
zugelassen werden können wenn sie
nachweislich nur mit synthetischen
Kraftstoffen betankt werden können denn
klimaneutrale Mobilitätsangebote zu
verbieten macht nun wirklich keinen Sinn
er denkt an e-fuels Kraftstoffe die ohne
Rohöl hergestellt werden aus möglichst
grünem Strom und Wasser wird Wasserstoff
gewonnen dazu gibt man CO2 aus der
Umwelt fertig ist ein klimaneutraler
Ersatz Sprit mit vielen
Einsatzmöglichkeiten Nachteil efield
sind teuer in der Herstellung die
Wirkungsverluste sind sehr hoch sollen
damit Autos fahren ich habe den Eindruck
dass das eher
ein Profilierungsversuch der FDP ist
allerdings auf Kosten von Arbeitsplätzen
Industrie und Klimaschutz Berliner
Streit auf Brüssels Bühne das späte 9
kostet Glaubwürdigkeit meinen selbst die
die für den Verbrenner kämpfen ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob in Berlin klar ist
was dieser Koalitionsstreit in Brüssel
bedeutet in der Sache volle
Unterstützung aber am Ende kommt der
Bundesverkehrsminister mit dieser
internation eindeutig zu spät eine für
Dienstag geplante Abstimmung wurde
verschoben am Wochenende trifft die
kommissionspräsidentin die
Bundesregierung wenn die dann eine
Meinung hat wäre das hilfreich
ja mal sehen Theo Paul was treibt die
FDP da an und inwiefern belastet dass
die Ampel
entweder hat der Verkehrsminister das
ganze verschlafen und erst in letzter
Minute die Reißleine gezogen was ich für
eher unwahrscheinlich halte oder es geht
hier wirklich um eine liberale
Profilierung und die wahrgenommene
Verteidigung von verbrennermotoren in
jedem Fall scheint der politische
Flurschaden in der EU erheblich zu gut
erhalten kann man der FDP und Minister
wissen dass sie diese Türe zu den efuels
ja schon immer offen halten wollten
quasi als Türe zur
technologieoffenheit schon im
Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel steht
wörtlich setzen wir uns dafür ein dass
nachweisbar nur mit efuels betankbare
Fahrzeuge neu zugelassen werden können
und auch im Arbeitsauftrag der
Kommission ist das Thema drin wenn auch
nur in einer rechtlich nicht bindenden
Zusatzklausel das Ganze wirkt aber so
wie Zara weil ja wesentliche deutsche
Autobauer die Weichen längst anders
gestellt haben der audi-Chef z.B sagt
bei Pkws würden e-fuels mittelfristig
keine große Rolle spielen bei Flugzeugen
und Schiffen da könnte es vielleicht
noch anders aussehen wegen des dort
schwierigeren
batterieeinsatzes und wie es sich so
fügt ist Ursula von der Leyen die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin ja am
Wochenende zu Gast auf der
kabinettklausur der Ampel in Meseberg da
werden ja sowieso reichlich Konflikte
ausgetragen zwischen grün und FDP und da
fällt dann vielleicht am Rande auch noch
einen gesichtswander Kompromiss bei uns
ab
beobachten Dankeschön nach Berlin
für den Klimaschutz und weniger
Verkehrsstaus wäre es natürlich eh
besser wenn die Leute weniger Auto
fahren und mehr in öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln unterwegs sind einen
Anreiz dazu soll das sogenannte
deutschland-ticket geben geplanter Staat
ist am ersten Mai heute ging der
Gesetzentwurf in den Bundesrat Prinzip
sind die Bundesländer dafür wollen aber
vom Bund mehr Geld schließlich müsste
der Nahverkehr auch weiter ausgebaut
werden das gilt natürlich vor allem auf
dem Land wie Daniela Sonntag in
Thüringen zeigt nächste Haltestelle
Weidmannsheil eine Reise ohne Gäste
niemand zugestiegen bei Busfahrer Lukas
Wagner auf dem Weg durch thüringische
Schwarzatal ob sich das ändert wenn das
deutschland-ticket kommt die meisten die
haben ein Autoführerschein manche die
haben Verwandtschaft die mit dem Auto
fahren ich denke mal das
deutschland-ticket das wird da schon mit
helfen aber alleine bringt das nicht
denn viele rechnen ganz genau mag Tage
Rudolstadt hier im ländlichen Thüringen
ist das auch der Tag an dem mehr los ist
auf dem Busbahnhof wenn sich viele
Menschen vom Dorf ihren Tag nach dem
Fahrplan einrichten Deutschland Ticket
im Abo für 49 € gemischte Reaktionen
für Saalfeld Rudolstadt bezahlt man 33 €
oder 34 und die kleinen 40 €, weil das
kosten soll am Anfang
gibt mir gar nichts hilf mir überhaupt
nicht ja das ist günstig für mich bin
Rentnerin was haben sie dann damit vor
meinen Kindern öfters noch was
Blankenburg zu fahren es lohnt sich für
allem für die die jetzt schon öfter
fahren sagen die Chefs vom
Verkehrsverbund Mittelthüringen und im
Nahverkehrsunternehmen kombus in
Saalfeld von gut 9.000 Abos sind hier
8000 Schülertickets Menschen vom Auto
wegzulocken eine Herausforderung nutzen
kannst natürlich nur der wo auch ein
Angebot ist und das ist teilweise in den
Dörfern in den Bergen schwierig und
deswegen hoffen wir dass nach Einführung
des deutschland-tickets ganz schnell
ganz viel Geld in den Ausbau von
öpnv-angeboten fließt das günstige
Ticket nur ein Anfang so sehen das auch
etliche Länder Verkehrsminister heute im
Bundesrat und fordern mehr Geld vom Bund
auch die Investition in moderne
Triebwagen in alternative
Antriebstechnologien und das ist mit dem
bisherigen Budget was wir auch als
Länder zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen
haben nicht zu leisten die Antwort aus
dem Verkehrsministerium Verhalten
gleichzeitig wurden ja bereits
zusätzliche Mittel des Bundes in die
Regionalisierungsmittel gegeben damit
können auch Kostensteigerungen an Stück
weit mit aufgefangen werden aber die
Bundesregierung ist nicht verantwortlich
für die Inflation und am Ende wird es
wohl auch ums Personal gehen allein
Combos fehlen derzeit 20 Busfahrer Lukas
Wagner braucht sich deshalb wohl keine
Gedanken um seinen Job zu machen nur um
die Anfahrt kommen sie dann zur Arbeit
mit dem Auto viel Arbeit noch am ÖPNV
[Applaus]
jetzt geht's bei dir noch mal weiter
Heinz zunächst mit einer Meldung aus der
Wirtschaft ja die Einzelhandel im
Bereich Textilien Bekleidung Schuhe hat
im vergangenen Jahr ein deutliches
Umsatz plus erreicht aber die Corona
bedingten Verluste aus den beiden
Vorjahren konnte die Branche noch nicht
wett machen so zog der Statistische
Bundesamt vor kurzem Bilanz und heute
war der realer sorgt ein großer
Modehändler für Schlagzeilen genau und
es geht um Peak und Cloppenburg
Düsseldorf nicht zu verwechseln mit P
und C Hamburg die Düsseldorfer Modekette
ist in Schieflage geraten und will sich
mit einem Schutzschirm Verfahren
sanieren das bedeutet noch nicht das
Ende denn diese insolvenzvariante ist
auf Rettung in Eigenregie ausgerichtet
den Management wird ein Samira zur Seite
gestellt ja und die 67 Filialen stand
jetzt die sollen erhalten bleiben ebenso
wie die Mitarbeiter in den Läden noch
ein Riese der Modebranche kommt ins
Wanken dabei war Peak und Cloppenburg
Düsseldorf Jahrzehnte lang ein fester
und solider Bestandteil der deutschen
innen doch die corona-krise kostete die
Modekette Millionen an Umsätzen und den
Onlinehandel hat sie lange verschlafen
hinzu kamen der ukraine-krieg und die
hohen Preise die Menschen kauften abrupt
weniger und die die es noch tun wollen
entweder super billig einkaufen bei
modedescountern oder super teuer bei
Luxusmarken das mittlere Segment
hingegen hat es schwer Verlierer sind
nicht nur die Läden auch die Innenstädte
in vielen Fußgängerzonen stehen schon
jetzt etliche Geschäfte leer und ein
Leerstand zieht oft den nächsten an ganz
anders die Stimmung auf dem Frankfurter
Parkett der DAX heute im Höhenflug mit
250 Punkten starker Wochen Ausklang an
der Börse damit rückt im DAX das 12
Monats hoch wieder in Sichtweite
vielen Dank
bei der Nordischen Ski-WM im
slowenischen Planitzer sind die
deutschen Skispringer heute ohne
Medaille geblieben bester war Markus
eisenbichler auf Rang 5 gewonnen hat der
Slowenien Team
aus Japan und David Kubatzki aus Polen
erfolgreicher waren die Deutschen langen
Läufer die Männerstaffel kam hinter
Norwegen und Finnland aufrang drei und
holte also Bronze
das ist für alle vier die erste
WM-Medaille
Startläufer Albert Kuchler hält das Team
im Rennen Janosch Brugger fällt 18
Sekunden zurück dann kann Jonas Dobler
die Lücke schließen bevor der Allgäuer
Friedrich mocht den Zielsprint vor
Frankreich für Deutschland entscheidet
einen Tag nach dem Silber der
Frauenstaffel der nächste Langlauf Kuh
es sollen sie die die auf den Preis
gefurzger die Tür ein bisschen früher
ins Bett gehen aber alle anderen müssen
feiern goldgitter Norwegen vor Finnland
für Deutschland ist es die zwölfte
Medaille eine mehr als bei der bisher
erfolgreichsten WM vor sechs Jahren
sollte die Bundeswehr mehr Geld bekommen
zusätzlich zum 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen das ist eine der Fragen
die die Forschungsgruppe Wahlen für das
neue ZDF Politbarometer gestellt hat
alle Ergebnisse präsentiert ihn jetzt
Matthias former
[Musik]
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer
klimaproteste Friedensdemos Streiks für
höhere Löhne und Gehälter Deutschland
kämpft sich durch die Krisen und zeigt
sich in wichtigen Fragen gespalten
Russlands Krieg gegen die Ukraine
überlagert dabei alle anderen Themen
doch auch die Sorgen ums Klima und die
womöglich verheerenden Folgen sind groß
dass die Bundesregierung zu wenig für
den Klimaschutz tut sagen 48 Prozent 27
Prozent finden die Maßnahmen gerade
richtig so fast jeder fünfte meint die
Bundesregierung tut zu viel in Sachen
Klimaschutz je jünger die Befragten
desto ausgeprägter die Kritik gut zwei
Drittel der unter 30-Jährigen sagen dass
die Bundesregierung zu wenig tut um das
Klima zu schützen bei den Befragten ab
60 sieht das weniger als die Hälfte so
mit den Schulstreiks von Greta Thunberg
nahm die weltweite Klimabewegung vor
vier Jahren ihren Anfang damals glaubte
etwa jeder zweite Befragte dass der
Druck der jungen Menschen die Politik zu
mehr Klimaschutz bewegen werde
inzwischen zeigen sich da viele
skeptisch oder ernüchtert
dass die Politik wegen der klima-demos
und Proteste mehr für den Klimaschutz
tut glauben jetzt 24 Prozent fast drei
Viertel der Befragten gehen nicht davon
aus
schauen wir auf die im Bundestag
vertretenden Parteien wenn am nächsten
Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre käme die SPD
auf 21% plus eins
cdu/csu auf 29 Prozent minus 1 die
Grünen 18 Prozent auch leichte Verluste
die FDP 5 unverändert die AFD 15 + 1 und
die Linke 5% konstant
damit würde es reichen für eine
Koalition aus Union und SPD und auch
ganz knapp für Schwarz-Grün nicht
reichen würde es für die regierende
Ampelkoalition und ebenso wenig für
Rot-Grün rot
schauen wir auf unsere Top Ten also die
Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung
Alice Weidel ist da weiter Schlusslicht
-2,6 verbessert
vorletzte Sarah
wagenknecht-1,3 deutlich schlechter
Christian Lindner minus 0,3 Karl
Lauterbach minus 0,2 verschlechtert
davor Friedrich Merz -0,1 etwas besser
Markus Söder 0,0 etwas schlechter
Annalena baerbock 0,5 ebenfalls etwas
verschlechtert auf dem dritten Platz
Robert Habeck 0,5 mit deutlichen
Einbußen Olaf Scholz zweiter 0,6 etwas
schlechter und mit großem Abstand vorn
Boris Pistorius 1,7 etwas verbessert
der neue Verteidigungsminister fordert
jetzt zusätzliche Mittel um das
nato-ziel von zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts für
Verteidigungsausgaben zu erreichen
62% der Befragten fänden ist gut wenn
die Bundeswehr dieses zusätzliche Geld
erhielte auch wenn dann an anderer
Stelle Einsparungen oder Schulden
gemacht werden müssten knapp ein Drittel
ist dagegen
in der Ukraine sind die Fronten trotz
heftiger Kämpfe weitgehend festgefahren
Kiew plant offenbar eine
Frühjahrsoffensive und Präsident
selenski schwört sein Volk darauf ein
alle Gebiete auch die Halbinsel Krim
zurückzuerobern doch auch die Rufe nach
Verhandlungen werden lauter weil dieser
Krieg allein mit Waffen nicht zu
gewinnen sei wie sollte sich der Westen
verhalten
41 Prozent meinen der Westen sollte die
Ukraine dazu drängen für einen möglichen
Frieden Gebietsverluste in Kauf zu
nehmen genauso viele sagen dagegen der
Westen sollte die Ukraine dabei
unterstützen alle Gebiete inklusive der
Krim zurückzuerobern
schauen wir zum Schluss noch einmal auf
diesen Freitag in Deutschland an dem in
vielen Städten wegen Streiks Busse und
bahnenstill standen vor allem um die
hohe Inflation auszugleichen fordern die
Gewerkschaften für den öffentlichen
Dienst
10,5% höhere Löhne und Gehälter
diese Forderung ist zu hoch finden 45%
der Befragten genauso viele finden es
gerade richtig so dass die Forderung zu
niedrig ist meinen nur fünf Prozent
wahrscheinlich blühen uns in diesem
Frühjahr noch einige Streiks und
Einschränkungen denn auch in anderen
Branchen kämpfen die Gewerkschaften für
mehr Geld
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite 165
in der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
Zustandekommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den Qualitätsstandards
finden Sie unter politbarometer.zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es dann am
17 März hier folgt jetzt das Wetter
danach geht es weiter mit der heute-show
viel Spaß dabei und einen schönen Abend
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute ist Tag des
Artenschutzes da gibt es viel zu tun
Beispiel Flüsse 90 Prozent der Deutschen
Flüsse Folgen nicht mehr ihren
natürlichen Verlauf darunter leiden
Ökosysteme begradigt wurden Flüsse einst
um waren einfacher zu transportieren so
verschwand Lebensraum dass das keine
gute Idee war haben wir inzwischen
verstanden und versetzen vor allem
kleinere Flüsse wie der in ihren
ursprünglichen Zustand zwei Drittel
eignen sich dafür besonders bis zu 1.900
km Flüsse könnten so freier fließen
Auenwälder entstehen Tiere und Pflanzen
siedeln sich an renaturierte Fluss
Ökosysteme schützen zudem bei Hochwasser
da sie Überflutungsflächen bieten und
Hochwasserwellen abflachen
Hochwasser brauchen wir jetzt vorerst
nicht zu befürchten auch wenn das Wetter
deutlich schmuddeliger wird interessant
wird es aber erst Anfang der kommenden
Woche wenn ein Tief über Dänemark weiter
bis ins Baltikum zieht an der weißen
Farbe sehen sie dass es in den Bergen
einige Zentimeter Neuschnee geben wird
heute Nacht gibt es auch schon ein ganz
bisschen schnee-riese oder Nieselregen
da ist Glätte nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen im Süden ist es dagegen
klar da singen die Werte bis -6 Grad das
bildet sich Nebel Morgen zeigt sich die
Sonne vom Bayerischen Wald bis zum
Oberrhein dort klettern bis 10 Grad im
Dauergrau sind es dagegen nur ein Grad
es wird meist trüb bleiben hin und
wieder kann es ein bisschen Schnee oder
Regen geben am Sonntag fällt mehr Schnee
oder Regen am Montag gibt's kaum Sonne
und am Dienstag drohen Wintergewitter im
Norden guten Abend